because but these streets got better
[Music]
I mean the fact that in 1979 with less
computing power than your smartphone has
people flew half a million miles
round-trip to the moon and back and
survived and been managed to bring all
these amazing rocks back that have
taught us about the entire solar system
it's just as a geologist these are the
holy grail for for for science
good
gives them all
they're actually priceless I mean we at
this point we can't go back and get any
more there are plans to do so but this
is what we have right now is what we
have so they're very worth being
protected
you already seen a spender we don't want
that and so and again that was playing
for money it's for more than one mission
in the same cabinet the reason we have
so many cabinets and each mission gets
its own cabinet and Apollo 16 17 to two
cabinets because they brought that half
the mass and that allows us to work on
them there's a hundred and twenty-five
groups around the world who are actually
studying the sample so it's my job to
get them the best samples possible and
actually make everyone else's science
better and for me that's really
satisfying everything from large bag
samples like this it's just like the
sample that's on display out there
will display samples that was made from
the original gives us information on the
earliest history in our solar system
where the record just doesn't exist
anymore on the earth
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so the two they're gonna get open are
this one here and that one there
those are both from Apollo 17 so this
one was sealed under vacuum on the moon
and then brought back never open science
instruments are four five six
generations more sensitive and we can do
more with the milligram than we can do
with the gran back then
I'm impressed they didn't have time to
switch on later initiative job each time
I put my hands in the cabinet and pick
up a sample I think about okay this came
from the moon you know and because he
came
Charlie Duke King Apollo Washington
University yes when I was there
[Music]